I want to know boy or girl
I'm not I ain't telling this ain't a
birth announcement all right this time
Ryan Reynolds and Blake Lively aren't
sharing too many details about their
newest addition to the family all
appearing on cnbc's power lunch the
hosts had to ask about baby number four
after the news broke earlier this week
and while no details have been shared
about the baby's gender or name it seems
like they are loving settling in as a
family of six we're very excited look we
wouldn't do this four times if we didn't
love it how are they how are they
sleeping how's Blake doing is she
sleeping uh everybody's doing great and
I everybody's actually doing fantastic I
mean we haven't figured it out by now I
think it would be in deep deep trouble
but at the same time having three young
daughters and a newborn can be really
challenging it's a zoo over here I mean
this is like a this is my office here
this is where I'll probably actually to
be honest I'll probably spend the rest
of my life In Here Blake seemed to
announce the news of their baby's
arrival on Super Bowl Sunday during a
snap alongside her hubby and her mom
Tammy the actress wrote Puppy Bowl
Sunday 2023 been busy many fans noticing
her bump was absent from the snaps Anna
Source has since told People magazine
Blake and Ryan are amazing together Ryan
is a great dad he is very sweet to Blake
they are very excited about the new
babies the older siblings have adjusted
great